Tim Phillips fine I am an assistant
professor at the Gallatin school of New
York University
well conservatism it people who write
about conservatism nOCA the idea is a
vexed one in some ways that conservatism
as a political ideology contains within
itself several different strands that
are in some ways really at odds with
each other
so one strand flows from I guess you
would say the reaction against the
French Revolution and Edmund Burke and
the whole idea that it's impossible for
people to consciously make efforts to
change society that doing so is
dangerous that it destroys tradition it
destroys organic social relationships
and that it just is it ultimately will
will lead to violence and and social
chaos so in some ways you shouldn't
really try to change anything you should
it's the only way that things can change
and should changes or slowly through
unconscious processes and the working
out of organic relationships so I think
that's kind of one one strain is an
attempt to conserve things to keep them
the same to not allow too rapid or
radical change this in some ways is at
odds with the other kind of major stream
of modern conservatism which focuses on
the market and allowing the market to do
its work without interference from the
state and the thing is that even those a
lot of continuity between these
positions in some ways where you know
the people people are Pro market want to
prevent the conscious intervention of
the state or of collective groups
imposing their will on the market so in
that in that sense a certain hostility
to the use of Reason or to any effort or
any belief that people really can shape
their own history a sense you should
stand back and let things happen
at the same time this the market itself
is brings about radical social
transformations and economic development
and capitalism the the growth of
capitalism really radically transforms
all of those older the social
relationships it changes family life it
changes community life it changes
religious life so those kind of bulwarks
of society that for berkians seem so
important to protect are actually really
threatened by the market so in this way
these two sides of conservatism
intellectually seem at odds with each
other at the same time I think they do
have that they do have certain
underlying similarities
you know this hostility to rationality
this sense that inequality is acceptable
okay the the necessary way of the world
in its this certain hostility to the
state so there it's a funny thing on the
one hand they're different on the other
they have certain tendencies that may be
or not as different as they might seem
well I think the the the way people see
the modern conservative movement in
America has gone through several shifts
one kind of what the oftentimes the the
way it's been seen is is that there was
a kind of dominance of liberalism in the
immediate post-war period after World
War two liberalism was dominant and it
was really only in the late 60s wet that
it began to break down when when the
liberal order was attacked by the new
left and by radical groups which in turn
were attacked by kind of their the
radicalism of these groups prompted a
backlash from the people who had
previously made up the backbone of the
Democratic Party white working-class
ethnic voters in in in cities in the
north and also the support of the white
South for the Democratic Party so
frequently the way it's been seen is
that there was this backlash in the late
60s and early 70s and that led to
Nixon's election and then later on to
Vegas election at the end of the 70s and
and the decline of the New Deal order so
that's that's one way it's been seen and
however there always been other other
ways that historians have seen the rise
of American conservatism many have
linked it back to the immediate post-war
period itself when you see the growth of
an intellectual conservatism the
founding of National Review in the mid
50's the some people go back even
further to the New Deal and see the
reaction against the New Deal as the
real birth point of modern conservatism
so there's an and the the suggestion
that there's been you know kind of the
growth of a grassroots conservative
activism throughout the 50s and 60s and
70s and that that that movement that
kind of forward-looking grassroots
movement is really what has given them
given conservatism it's staying power
not just the the backlash of the late
60s and early 70s but also this longer
underlying trends I mean I think they're
historians to go further still and say
the Ku Klux Klan the you know the rise
of big business in the late 19th century
that there that you can find the
dominance before the New Deal of Alessa
fair set of economic ideas that all of
these parts kind of racial conservatism
will just fundamentalism market ideology
all of those things go back before the
New Deal and so in some ways they were
there waiting to be reawakened so that's
yet another view
well I would say first well one thing is
I think the Republican Party is
different from the conservative movement
and really especially in the post-war
period this is important to keep in mind
because there were also liberal
Republicans and so there's a lot of
tenants who are not you know they're not
the same and also the concern movement I
think has had a lot of impact on
Democrats as well so it in some ways
it's it's always a little confusing what
the relationship is between the
political parties and these social
movements well I think the you know
there are I guess there are different
schools of thought about this but the
concern that suggests that the ability
of conservatives to attract these very
dedicated grassroots activists in places
like Orange County California that that
enabled the movement to just kind of
slowly grow almost under the radar
screen until it was a kind of
consolidated its power and that the
activists carrying out the work of the
movement we're doing really the same
kind of thing that civil rights
activists were doing or labor act the
union activists are doing they're
they're slowly kind of meeting people
one on one holding coffee klatches
participating in rallies that kind of
activity and slowly but surely they
built a movement
I think though that it actually is
problematic to see conservatism as a
purely grassroots movement and that one
of the things that really makes the
conservative movement different is that
it's always been able or throughout the
post-war period it's always been able to
attract a lot of support from business
organizations and from very wealthy
individuals and donors and that there
that these people have played I would
argue a disproportionate role in driving
the movement forward so in some ways
what you really need to kind of ride out
defeats but you need to ride out you
know the losses that are part of any
attempt to change society one thing you
really two need is you need money and
infrastructure and conservatives have
access to that in a way that I think
labor activists just don't and and civil
rights activists don't and so they are
able to you know survive to feed in part
because they are connected to people who
have a lot of social power regardless so
I think you know the grassroots activism
is an important part of the story but
it's not the whole story you need to
look at the financing and the
institutions and the role of the role of
companies and these groups that don't
rise and fall with elections or with
particular legislative battles
all right do people see conservatives
differently well I think it is
McCrea Lee since we have the election
it's interesting we've seen an enormous
amount of condescension and hostility
that from liberal groups towards
conservatives and it is a combination
it's both seeing them again as really
weird
you know freakish outside the mainstream
and you know a lot of the ideas that are
being circulated in the consumer today
are kind of crazy and paranoid I mean
the idea that Obama isn't really an
American or the idea that you know that
this the image of the death panels for
healthcare I mean there is something
really paranoid about these ideas you
know at the same time I also think that
it is it it it is confusing and it
obscures the way things really are to
treat these people as though they are
you know with this with this kind of
just looking down on them and their
ideas and also I I guess one thing about
it is that it it merjan Eliza's the
extent to which a lot of the ideas of
the consumer I really entered the
mainstream and I think one of the things
that we really need to look at today
historians and anybody interested in
politics is the that are the successes
of the conservative movement and the way
that it really has been able to shape
both political parties and the whole way
that we think about politics may we
think about the market the way we think
about the role of the state it seems to
me that in some ways what people
shouldn't start to do is stop studying
only the conservatives and start looking
at you know the mainstream and the
consensus and how that has shifted I
think in large part as a result of the
the work of the conservative movement
but you know kind of conceived broadly
well I think and I think that the
biggest the deepest impact is really in
economic ideas and there's just a lot
that the kind of old confidence and the
idea that the state could you know that
by taking the state had the ability to
take positive action in order to to
change economic relationships and create
a more equal fair just economy I think
that the contemporary Democratic Party
you know even under Obama is not
committed to that in the same way and I
think one place we really see this
actually is with regard to labor unions
and the you know really complete lack of
commitment of the Obama administration
to passing labor law reform you know I
think we see it all over though I mean I
think you can see it in the health care
debate and the way in which what's
actually being talked about now is is
substantially watered down and it's
quite far from a you know anything like
a single-payer program which might
actually which many experts think we
would have the you know greatest chance
of actually delivering on the goal of
truly universal health care but it's not
on the table it's just nowhere in the
discussion not nowhere but it's not it's
definitely not in the in it's not what's
being talked about in Congress so so I
think that kind of thing you know that
there's there's a way in which the the
center of political opinion has has
really shifted
is Obama post-partisan president well no
I don't I don't think that it it is I
think the whole concept of post-partisan
is is problematic and that it's you know
the way that things really change is
through people being willing to take
positions and and fight for them and I
think the idea you can avoid the fight
or transcendent in politics is just not
right and Obama as a community organizer
I should have known better you know I
think in the 1936 election we have FDR
speaking Madison Square Garden saying if
the forces of organized business our
against United against him and he
welcomes their hatred that's not a post
partisan position but that is the kind
of position that you need to I think
really make things change and I think
with Obama it's interesting he could he
tries you know to you you back away from
conflict but the it's impossible to
actually avoid it I mean you know in the
ways in which he's been attacked for the
reforms that he's tried to put through
especially in health care you can see
this dynamic where he's putting
something forward that seems quite
moderate really but it doesn't matter
how moderate it is it still gets
attacked and so that's why I think it's
it's it's I don't think he has a post
partisan president but I also think it
wasn't really the right thing to try for
well this is a great question will the
Republican Party come back in the
midterm elections will it come back in
2012 I I think that is you know as a
historian it's so it's so dangerous to
predict the future and one is very
reluctant to you know really play
fortune-teller I don't know whether
we'll come back in midterm elections or
in 2012 it's certainly the it certainly
seems like it's in a lot of internal
chaos right now no good leaders emerging
it seems to be playing in almost
entirely a kind of negative role in
terms of attacking Obama and but not not
able to really formulate a coherent
response at the same time I think the
you know I think that the the underlying
dynamics that gave it strength in the
past are still there I mean it continues
to have cadres of grassroots activists
who are very committed to it as we've
seen in the disruptions of the the
healthcare town halls over the summer
and the tax day protests and the like
and it also continues to have I think
the support of a large number of
business people and a kind of
intellectual infrastructure of think
tanks and political organizations
devoted to not the Republican Party
necessarily at all times but certainly
to a anti-government set of positions
and I think that if Obama did try to
take things further to the left that we
would see a stronger reaction against it
from those groups and from those people
and unless you know unless there's
another kind of political movement that
comes into existence around something
like health care that can really counter
it I think that they you know the
underlying ins for conservative success
are still there they haven't really
changed so I don't know whether will
happen in
the midterm elections or 2012 but I
definitely think I wouldn't write the
Republican Party or that kind of
movement conservatism off as dead by by
a longshot
well I think that today there is there's
a the the Republican Party seems like
it's really divided in these different
single-issue groups and although you
know there are certain I mean I think
it's it's not you know I think there's
no about it there's been a lot of
discussion of the centrality of social
issues in the conservative movement
today and the sense that and you know
different conservative commentators
themselves like George will have
criticized the rest of the movement for
you know becoming too committed to these
social issues to abortion politics anti
gay marriage and and letting go kind of
the the the real issues of the market
and lower taxes and so on and so forth
and so there there's a sense that the
social conservatives are really running
the show you know I think that it is
complicated I mean III would both say
that it there's this question of what's
happened to the mainstream but even in
the Republican Party there are still a
lot of people who are very committed to
this low tax anti-regulation program the
problem is that I mean and and you know
I think that the two sides people have
always been able to kind of hold both
positions and even though it seems like
there ought to be a conflict in actual
practice there isn't and we can talk
more about you know how these positions
hold together but I think they do for
people and so it's not experienced as a
contradiction exactly I think the real
issue for the the real anti-government
the hardcore anti-government people in
Oakland the party is that the recession
and the financial crisis has really
called their ideology into question and
in a way that it hadn't been challenged
for some time and so just this sort of
pure market ideology now seems you know
irresponsible Mike it led to this this
huge panic and so I think it's harder to
advance it in the same kind of confident
directed way that we've seen in the past
I think you know it's funny you see the
other people in holding a party maybe in
response to the total failure of their
ideas with with recent economic events
trying to advance other ways out the
problem is that they're they're not from
for them is that they're really not
committed to it and so you know I just
think it creates real problems
there's just something two contradictory
about saying the state can be used in
this way but not that way and I don't
know I think it's internally incoherent
for them
I think it's just hard to be a
libertarian today or to win new
supporters to libertarian causes you
know in the wake of the recession and
fiscal financial crisis at the same time
I think there's a lot of criticism of
the bailout and of the actions of the
state with regard to the auto industry
and a sense that Obama represents
business interests in some ways or has
been willing to work with business
people and hasn't taken them on directly
and I think this actually does fuel a
certain libertarianism I see and among
my students actually a sense that
there's this relationship between
business and government and neither is
really standing for the market and that
the market is the way to you know
success and prosperity for everybody so
I feel like that that idea actually is
given a lot of strength by the you know
by things like the bailout and by
Obama's relationship with the financial
sector and banking industry and so I
think that that kind of thing
I mean that actually would speak to the
a more rapid resurgence of conservatism
I suppose this sense that there's this
cozy nexus and a feeling of being
Outsiders and wanting you know a kind of
economic life it isn't in this
relationship of the state